One, two...
[scats]
(all)
♪ There goes the girl
who owns my heart ♪
♪ I knew she was the one
right from the start ♪
- ♪ Ooh-wah ♪
- ♪ Our love is here to stay ♪
- ♪ Each and every day ♪
♪ We know that we will
never part ♪
[scats]
(Lyle)
Oh, wow.
Great work, everybody.
Troy, I love that little
Motown outro thing.
Super soulful.
Cool.
Thanks, Lyle.
Yeah, it just, uh, came to me,
so I went with it.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Hey, is this where
the a cappella group meets?
- Oh, hey, Mark.
- Hey, Lyle.
What's going on, buddy?
- Mark, get over here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Lyle)
Guys, this is my buddy, Mark.
He just transferred
from Minnesota.
I thought he could sit in
on a few practices.
I don't know,
maybe join the group?
Maybe.
[chuckles]
(Lyle)
All right, guys.
Let's do "Always Been My Girl"
again, from the top.
- "Always Been My Girl," okay.
- And...Mark?
- Show us your stuff.
- You got it, man.
- (Lyle)
All right, guys.
Ready?
- One, two...
- [scats]
(all)
♪ There goes the girl ♪
♪ Who owns my heart ♪
♪ I knew she was the one
right from the start ♪
- ♪ Ooh wah ♪
- ♪ Our love is here to stay ♪
- ♪ Each and every day ♪
♪ We know that we will
never part ♪
[scats]
♪ Ooh-wee-ee-ooh ♪
[all laugh and clap]
(Lyle)
You got to be kidding me.
Mark, that was
out of this world.
Oh, gosh, okay, well, hey,
it just came to me,
so I just went with it.
(Lyle)
Great.
Well, keep going with it.
Guys, have a safe weekend,
all right?
- See you on Monday.
- Nice to meet you guys, man.
- That was awesome.
- Isn't he the best?
Cool, guys.
Great practice.
- Troy, good effort.
- All right.
[Troy laughs]
Yeah, check you later, guys.
See you later, alligators.
[ominous music]
♪ ♪
The [bleep] you think
you doing, [bleep]?
I'm doing my thing, [bleep].
The [bleep] you doing?
See...
this is my seven white boys,
[bleep].
- [scoffs]
- You need to back
the [bleep] up.
[bleep] that, [bleep].
I'm 'bouts to get mine.
Do you have any idea
how long it took
for me to infiltrate
this group, [bleep]?
25 minutes.
You think I'm gonna
roll over
for some falsetto-ass
mother[bleep]?
[scoffs]
Well, you know what, [bleep]?
White boys is gonna do
what white boys is gonna do.
And if they want to run
with a high-ass-singing
falsetto [bleep],
then that's on them.
Oh, that's on them, then?
Oh, that's on them,
then.
Okay, so it's like that?
Oh, it's so
like that.
Well, watch your back, [bleep]!
- Okay.
- Watch your back, [bleep]!
'Cause you [bleep]
with my [bleep],
I'll [bleep] with your [bleep],
[bleep]!
[echoing]
(man)
And improvise.
Oh, it's so cold out,
and it's going to be dark soon.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we should build a fire.
Right, yeah, um, like...
Oh! Fire! Fire!
Freeze!
Oh, no.
It's a black cat.
Hey, man.
Why the cat
got to be black?
[laughter]
Freeze!
[dramatic music]
♪ ♪
Man, I guess I got to put
my dick away.
[laughter]
[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪